While there might not appear to be a correlation between
the two variables, let's think about this a little bit
more. What's on the x-axis? Months. And what's on the
y-axis? Temperature. So, we know that this month variable is
very discreet. We'll have the months from January to December,
and they'll repeat over and over again. Let's be sure
we add that detail to our plot. Here's the code
that we used to create the plot using the ggplot syntax.
What layer and syntax would you add to
this plot in order to make that change? Type
in your code here. You'll want to break
open the x-axis every 12 months, so that way
it corresponds to a year. I'll let you
figure out what the lower and upper limits of
the x axis should be. So, what do
you think? What layer and syntax should we add?